we're going to begin this NewsHour in
the east of Ukraine where at least 30
people have been killed in a rocket
attack Ukrainian officials say Russia
struck a train station in the city of
kramatosk an evacuation effort was
underway when two rockets hit the
station more than a hundred people were
wounded Ukrainian president of Vladimir
zielinski described Russia as an evil
with no limits after the attack Done Yet
separatists have described it as
Ukrainian provocation well let's speak
to Assad bagh now who's in kharki Forest
let's start with this attack on the
train station what more do we know about
it I said
well we know that for the last five days
the government of the regional Governor
has been telling people not to wait and
to leave Crema toast now it is about 200
kilometers away from his in the east of
the country now people were flocking to
that train station wanting to evacuate
to safer parts of the country now some
of the latest information that we have
from the regional Administration is that
the preliminary figures at the moment
that 27 dead including two children and
over 30 uh injured now they've said that
it's preliminary that could change and
the pictures that we've been seeing are
absolutely harrowing people strewn
across the floor outside that train
station but people are still wanting to
leave because the fear is that Russia is
mounting again or getting ready for a
new offensive in the east of the country
will be a part of that that's where they
will be concentrating so it is a very
very tragic scene that we're seeing lots
of pictures and a video that we've been
seeing but those people still want to
leave the advice from the governor and
the officials have been to leave the
area to save a part of the country
during khaki as I mentioned the Hakim
has been seeing constant shelling
certainly for the last few hours just
tell us what's been happening there
well this morning we've been here
constantly we've been hearing constant
shedding and artillery fire we've heard
anti-aircraft fire we saw a heard an
aircraft above and saw it drop a bomb
also this morning but the administration
here says over the last 24 hours there's
been 48 incidents including a shell
hitting a hospital now they say that 15
people have been injured there's intense
fighting taking Place Southeast of
kharkif in a city called izum where the
Russians have control of that and it
seems like there is a lot of activity
taking place all night and all day we're
hearing the guns going off every few
minutes and that's just the norm here
currently but as I said the Russians
have said that they will start their new
phase where they want to concentrate on
the east of the country and the fear is
that things here in kharkiv Ukraine's
second largest city could get worse so
thank you very much indeed I said big
talking to us from let's go to dosto
dubari who's in Moscow for us and
mentioned before for the donets
separators have been saying that this
attack on the train station
they're describing it as a Ukrainian
provocation what's Moscow saying to all
of this
well we've been hearing from the Russian
defense minister here uh who say that
they reject the claims that Kiev is
making that they're responsible for this
attack according to the Russian defense
Ministry the tochkoyu missile that was
used in this attack is something that is
commonly used by the Ukrainian military
and the Russians had no activity in that
area on Friday April 8th and they also
highlight the fact that this is the same
kind of missile that was used on a
previous attack on March 14th in the
city of Donetsk that killed 17 people in
eastern Ukraine they are saying that
this is yet another provocation by the
part of the Ukrainian military to try
and engage the Russians in that area we
also want to highlight that this is the
region that the Russians have said they
want to concentrate the second phase of
their so-called special military
operation in that is the Eastern and
part of Ukraine according to Russian
officials earlier in March during those
talks in Istanbul they said that they
had completed phase one and they were
going to withdraw their troops from
around the Ukrainian Capital Kiev and
they're going to focus on their
operation in eastern part of Ukraine of
course this is where it all started that
is in the
um Donetsk and lugansk region where
there are russian-backed separatists
groups that are trying to retake what
they claim is rightfully their land
which is part of Ukraine at the moment
and the fighting that has been going on
there is what the Russian military is
involved with
daughter so thank you very much indeed
dosage about it talking to us from
Moscow